we decided to celebrate cakes this
entire week because
you know why not i mean really it's
2020. bring on the cakes
and our next guest is a cake enthusiast
host of food network's girl meat farm
an award-winning blogger and author of
molly on the range and you can see
my book is completely annotated and
folded over please welcome someone who
i'm so freaking out to meet
molly yay
hi drew i am so freaking out to meet you
happy cake week this is the best week
ever officially
look at my cookbook can you like tell
how ridiculously dog weird
okay so i saw last night on instagram
that you made my
ex-boyfriend's meatless balls from that
bug and let me tell you drew that just
completely
validated that entire relationship
i have a few meatless ex-boyfriends too
so i totally get it
and um i just think that reading your
cookbook also you're
such an incredible storyteller i've
poured through your blog
i love your writing so much and your
whole life and your husband and your
baby and
it's cake week so let's do this what
cake are we making
okay we are making my chocolate chili
splatter cake
which is so rich and chocolatey and
moist
it's really easy to make and it's so
much fun to decorate
so tell me what to do okay so
i use my basic go-to chocolate cake here
which i love because you don't need a
stand mixer to make it you just need
two bowls and a whisk all the
ingredients are easy to have on hand at
all times for cake emergencies
the dry ingredients i always mix up
first it's just
flour sugar unsweetened cocoa powder
your leavening agents baking powder and
baking soda that's how beautifully this
is placed molly i really love this it's
like the dry ingredients but they're
like in a perfect
nick can you see that smell like can you
smell the cocoa powder
too i just love the certainly can making
cake
um and then i like to add a little bit
of cayenne pepper
because chocolate and chili go really
nicely together one of my favorite
things
that is in your book which i've never
seen anywhere is you have
um is it cayenne sprinkles
yeah you can okay did you know that you
can make your own sprinkles now that
it's cake week
you should try it it's so easy maybe we
could do a digital
pizza for how to make your own sprinkles
okay
and then when you make your own
sprinkles you can do different flavors
okay next we have the wet ingredients
i've got my eggs oil milk and then some
vanilla and you just whisk up the wet
ingredients
add it to the dry ingredients mix it up
okay and now
here comes my little tip once most of
these ingredients are incorporated
you add boiling water and the boiling
water helps the cocoa powder
to incorporate and bloom so it it
becomes its best version of itself when
it hits the boiling
water you could also use hot coffee but
the reason that you add it at the end is
because you don't want the boiling water
to cook the eggs
that were in the wet ingredient mixture
so this gets mixed up
and then you want to be careful not to
over mix it because that could create a
gummy cake and
nobody wants that once this batter is
mixed it goes
into the cake pans i'm using two eight
inch cake pans but you could also do
a sheet cake or cupcakes any shape you
want
gets baked at 350 for about 28 minutes
and then this is the frosting it's just
a basic american buttercream
it's softened butter powdered sugar a
little bit of milk
or instead of milk you could also use
booze depending on what mood you're in
cayenne coffee booze molly you're not
only the
british person you're also the coolest i
love you
i love it you are there i love you
okay so once you have your frosting and
your cake
you frost it to create this canvas
and now we're just going to mix up our
paints and
unleash our inner jackson pollock so the
paint all the paints are just powdered
sugar
and water or milk or any liquid
again you can use a little booze in here
too and then you mix it up with some
food coloring you can use
gel or liquid food coloring can i tell
you what lisa
and ashley did here who set this up by
the way
they did rainbow spatulas which i bet
are
yep their flower shop amira that match
it okay
i'm going can i splatter i love amirah
she's gonna come on this week
ready okay i'm going to be watching okay
now we're gonna splatter so you just
start off with a little bit and you just
drizzle it all over i mean it's not
rocket science here really
mine already looks crappy but i oh no it
doesn't it looks
gorgeous oh my god this is one of the
funniest things i've ever done and are
you kidding me it's so
funny and if you if you make it it
tastes good oh my god
molly oh my god i'm not kidding
i'm gonna go home and do this with my
daughters tonight my daughters
live oh my god
oh my god such a fun thing yeah you can
get the whole family involved
hold on
yes yes yes
that's it i did it go to our website for
the full recipe
and molly let's do everything together
in life i'm so in love with you i think
you're the coolest prettiest
neatest most wonderful thing and
everybody agrees because everybody loves
you so please let's do more go to the
drewberrymartial.com
[Music]